We're now going to take a look at adding rivers to our particular maps.
Now to use the river tools, again like we did with all of the other ones, we simply search
for water body river and then we click to add the river to our map.
We're going to get something that looks like this.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So we're going to come in here and we are going to go river and then we're just going
to click this water body river and we have added the river to our particular map.
Now with rivers, what we want to do is select our individual points here and just kind of
drag them along to make the river longer.
If we right click on them, let me just put the river all the way across the map like
this, right click, add spline points.
We can start to add various bends and shapes inside of the river that make it look a little
bit more like a river and a little less made inside of a computer.
If we come back to our water body river instance here, let me just pull this up so we can look,
just make sure that we're on it.
There we go.
Underneath our terrain, you can see here we have our channel depth, which again is going
to control the depth of the river right here.
So if we want a shallow river, we can set this to something like, you know, four or seven.
We'll get something that's very shallow.
We can adjust the ramp width, which will make the river narrow or wider.
However, there are a couple of other things that the river tool has the other tools do
not.
And that is if we click on the individual points and look for the water, we have our
depth, river width, velocity and audio intensity.
So the depth and the river width are going to be some properties that you mess with a
lot, as well as the velocity.
Now velocity controls how fast the river moves in a given direction.
So if we want the river to go one, one way, we make it positive.
If we want the river to go another way, we make it negative.
So let's just take a look at that right now.
So I'm going to come in here and I'm just select this one right here.
We're going to come all the way up to the top under our selected points and then water.
So depth, I can make this like 64 to make the river really, really shallow.
And then maybe I do this like, we'll just do the times two to make it 4096.
So I make the river very, very wide there.
The other thing I can do is set this velocity.
If I set this to zero, we're going to see there is no velocity there.
If I set this to a negative 128, we're going to see it actually flows the other direction.
One of the other cool things that you can do with rivers is that we could actually have
a bunch of rivers all put together.
So let's look at how we do that now.
All we need to do is either duplicate this river by holding alt and not alt.
I want the whole, whole river.
There we go.
Holding alt and duplicating the entire river.
And then what I can do is I can rotate this and they will actually intersect with the
other river bodies.
So you can see here, they're both intersecting.
We got one flowing one way and one flowing the other way.
We can take them apart.
They can flow across a river and then, you know, do something like that.
So we have actually two that are intersecting and then going, going across.
So that's some really cool, interesting stuff that we can do here.
And again, if we just, you know, right click, add a right click, add a spline point here,
we can get some really interesting looking shapes.
And then much like in this image here, we have a three different rivers that are all
crossing each other and going in and flowing in all together.
So really, really great stuff and interesting stuff that we can do with the river tools,
especially considering we can add multiple rivers to them.